So we're given the following
equation, that 5 times the
absolute value of x plus 3
minus 3 is equal to 7.
It's always a little daunting
to see an equation with an
absolute value sign.
And when you only have one of
them, like this, what I like
to do is isolate it, and just
kind of think it through from
that point.
So let's try to isolate
the absolute
value of x plus 3 here.
Let's try to isolate that
part of our equation.
So the first thing we might want
to do is add 3 to both
sides of the equation.
That'll get rid of this minus 3,
or this negative 3, on the
left-hand side.
So let's add 3 to both sides
of this equation.
And this'll turn the equation
into-- do it in that same pink
color --the left-hand side
will still be 5 times the
absolute value of x plus 3.
The minus 3, or the negative
3 plus the 3,
those will cancel out.
That'll just be 0.
And then that will be equal
to 7 plus 3, which is 10.
Now, we have 5 times the thing
we want to isolate.
The best way to isolate it
completely is to divide both
sides of this equation by 5.
So if you divide that side
by 5, and then the
right-hand side by 5.
We divide it by 5 so that these
guys will cancel out.
5 times something divided by
5 is just that something.
So these cancel out.
That's 2.
So we're left with the absolute
value of x plus 3 is
equal to 10 divided
by 5, which is 2.
So we've simplified the equation
a good bit, now we
just have to put our thinking
caps on a little bit.
If the absolute value of
something is 2, what does it
mean that that something is?
What are the two numbers that,
if I were take it's absolute
value, I could get 2.
I'll do a little thing
on the side here.
We know that the absolute value
of 2 is equal to 2.
So maybe this thing
was equal to 2.
So maybe x plus 3
is equal to 2.
If x plus 3 is equal to 2, and
you take its absolute value,
you're going to get 2 again.
But we also know that the
absolute value of negative 2
is also equal to 2.
So maybe x plus 3 is equal
to negative 2.
Because if x plus 3 is equal to
negative 2, and we take its
absolute value, then we're
going to get 2 again.
So we could also write or x
plus 3 could be equal to
negative 2.
That's what I mean
about thinking
about it a little bit.
Another way to think about it--
I've said this in other
videos --is absolute value
means distance from 0.
So if we were to draw a number
line here, that is 0, this is
saying that, whatever this
quantity is inside the
absolute value sign, its
distance from 0 is 2.
So what numbers are
2 away from 0?
Well, you have positive 2.
I'll write a positive
there explicitly.
And you also have
a negative 2.
So this thing here could be a
positive 2, or it could be a
negative 2.
Either way you take the absolute
value of a positive 2
or a negative 2, you're
going to get a 2.
So let's solve these.
So over here we can subtract
3 from both
sides of this equation.
So if you subtract 3 from both
sides, you get-- The left-hand
side, you're just
left with an x.
These 3's cancel out.
That's the whole point
of subtracting the 3.
x will be equal to 2 minus
3 is negative 1.
So that is one solution to our
absolute value equation.
And what's our other solution?
Well here, once again, let's
subtract 3 from both sides.
So you subtract 3
from both sides.
The left-hand side just
becomes an x.
The right-hand side, negative
2 minus 3 is negative 5.
So this is our other solution.
And let's verify that
they both work.
So if x is equal to negative
1, what does
this equation become?
We have 5 times the absolute
value of negative 1
plus 3 minus 3.
And if this really is a
solution, then this should be
equal to positive 7.
So let's see.
This is 5 times negative
1 plus 3 is 2.
So it's 5 times the absolute
value of 2 minus 3.
The absolute value
of 2 is just 2.
So this is 5 times 2 minus 3.
5 times 2 is 10 minus 3, which
is, indeed, equal to 7.
So this is definitely
a solution.
Let's try the other one out.
x is equal to negative 5.
Running out of some real estate,
but I could clear some
up right here.
If x is equal to negative
5, same drill.
5 times the absolute value of
negative 5 plus 3 minus 3.
This again should
be equal to 7.
Negative 5 plus 3
is negative 2.
Since there's 5 times the
absolute value of negative 2
minus 3, the absolute value of
negative 2 is positive 2.
So this is 5 times 2 minus 3,
which is 10 minus 3, which is
again equal to 7.
And notice, in this situation,
the thing in the absolute
value sign became a negative 2,
because we said, oh, x plus
3 could be equal
to negative 2.
In the magenta situation, the
thing in the absolute value
sign was positive 2, because
this was a situation where we
assumed that the thing in the
absolute value sign was a
positive 2.
Now if we were to graph these
solutions on the number line,
if we were to graph the two
solutions on a number line--
I'll draw a new number
line here.
Let me draw a new number
line, just like that.
Both of these are less than
0, so I'll put 0 all
the way over here.
Maybe 0, 1, 2.
Let's go negative, negative
1, negative 2, negative 3,
negative 4, negative
5, negative 6.
This solution right here-- x
is equal to negative 1 --we
could plot on the number
line right over there.
And then the other solution-- x
is equal to negative 5 --we
can plot it right over there.
Hopefully you found
that enjoyable.